Hello everyone, welcome to this week's episode of the Grand Prixquel podcast.
This week we're going to dive into the action in British F4 and F1 Academy, as well as exploring some recent news in Formula 3 and the F1 Academy rookie test.
So I say we just dive right into it. So starting with the Formula 3 train race, we've had Louis Sharp announce he's leaving Formula 3 and it's a certain Alex Powell replacing him.
I mean, you know, Robin will talk more about Alex Powell. I want to talk about Louis Sharp because from what he and like Prema posted, it sounded heavily like- I'm unsure because on Prema, the account, it sounded like he already has something lined up and he's getting ready for this.
But on his account, it sounded more like he's still unsure. And I've been wondering, I've checked as far as I saw, I think he should qualify for or be able to qualify for a Formula E license.
If you think back, he's like British F4, GB3 champion, he came third in Formula Regional Oceania, and I don't know if that's, you know, what he's doing.
But it could be or it could be a similar series that runs over the winter, which would make sense that he, even if he could finish the season, if he knows, you know, he's not far up in the standings, he's not fighting for the championship,
anything he would gain from here is irrelevant. It's a better choice for him to, you know, leave the championship and prepare for whatever comes next.
At least that's my hope because I think it would be really sad if he was completely out of his seat and had to leave F3 simply because he does not have the money anymore.
Yeah, I feel like maybe he's probably still figuring stuff out because also for Formula E, he only needs 20 super license points.
I'm not quite sure how far, you know, back–super license points–I always mix that up.
But with only GB3 and Formula Regional Oceania, he should have enough.
But I don't think he's tested even Formula E before.
So it's just wild card guess of mine because he's the kind of driver that I could see, you know, making that jump.
Maybe he's a development driver or something.
Or he'll go somewhere like sports cars around over the winter.
Other than that, F3 has been testing at Madrid, the new Madring.
You know, I feel like a bit of F3 stuff came out.
Also, Brad Benavides will not be returning for the rest of the season after his injury in Monaco.
So it's confirmed that we'll have Riccardo Escotto continue replacing him, which makes sense because it clashes with FREC.
So we don't have someone like Salim Hanna coming back into the seat.
And also so far, I feel like F3 did not work out for Salim the way that he would probably like it to work out.
So it's not worth, you know, doing the jump already.
Yeah, I think we will of course all hear from Robin more about Alex Powell.
I'll leave her to get into that.
Hi guys, Robin here.
It's been a while since I've been on an episode.
I will be back soon.
Don't worry.
But we figured as a podcast that it would be really important for me to, you know, come on and talk about the news.
So if you haven't heard, I'm sure we've already talked about it.
Like my fellow podcast hosts have already talked about, you know, the whole situation with Louis Sharp basically not having enough money to continue the F3 season.
I haven't actually listened to what everyone has said, so it'll be just as much of a surprise for me as it is for you guys.
But I need to paint a picture here.
In the couple hours between the news of Louis leaving F3 and, you know, the announcement of his replacement.
During those couple hours, I made a joke saying, oh, his replacement is going to be Alex Powell, but only for the first round because the second round clashes with Eurocup 3 Silverstone.
So imagine my surprise when I I'm not on my phone at that moment because I'm like not at home.
I go into a store with my mom.
My mom's looking at stuff around the store.
I open my phone and I get a flood of mentions on Twitter and like five billion DMs from people just being like Robin, Robin, Robin, Robin, like, oh, my God.
And I'm like, what the fuck is happening?
And so I checked to see what's happening and it's Alex Powell to replace Louis Sharp at Prema.
Again, I am in public at that point, so I could not freak out as much as I wanted to.
But obviously, I immediately obviously I immediately went to my parents and was like, oh, my God, guys, like, you will never believe what just happened.
But, um, that aside, at the time of recording, it is Tuesday afternoon or evening, whatever.
So the F3 tests at Madrid have just ended.
So I wanted to come and talk about those a little bit and just talk about my expectations with Alex in general.
First, what you need to know is that Alex has never driven an F3 car before.
Secondly, he's never driven a street track before, because all of the Italian F4, the two years that he did them, all of the UAE championships that he did and Eurocup 3 as well, they all race on permanent tracks.
So this Madrid test was his first ever time on a street track.
And thirdly, he's with Prema.
So it's safe to say that expectations are kind of really low.
At least my expectations were going into the test.
So the tests today were not really that great because they were interrupted by so many red flags.
Like the tests yesterday were also interrupted by a lot of red flags.
But Alex was able to do some competitive laps during that time, which unfortunately was not the case for today,
because any time he was setting a personal best sector one, someone caused a red flag during his sector two.
So he just couldn't really do much.
So that's why his results from the tests today were not great.
But I wanted to talk about yesterday's tests because he really did exceed my expectations.
He finished the first test in 16th and the second test in 18th.
The first test he finished 1.4 seconds off of the fastest time and the second test was 1.1 seconds off the fastest time.
And again, you have to consider all the stuff that I just mentioned about, you know, his lack of experience and just the fact that he's with Prema.
Personally, I thought to manage those results, I thought it was impressive from him because my expectations going into this was we need to beat Garfias and we need to finish higher than P20.
That is all I wanted.
Anything more than that was a bonus because while I think Alex is a better driver than Wharton,
Wharton has a ton of experience compared to Alex's zero.
So I was worried that Wharton's experience would mean that he would be quite a bit faster than Alex.
But we saw from the first test sessions that that wasn't the case.
Alex finished both sessions as the fastest pro and got Prema their highest finish of the entire testing weekend other than Wharton's P16.
In one of the sessions today, I think it was the morning session, but honestly, I did not keep up with the morning session.
I was dead asleep.
But yeah, I'm pretty excited to see how Alex will do in like a proper competitive session because obviously testing is really representative at the end of the day.
And like I said, there are a ton of red flags.
People were in the wall like constantly.
So we'll have to see how Alex will do in a proper, like, you know, quali session when Madrid comes around.
I am glad that he kept it out of the wall because there were so many drivers that were in the wall, including some talented drivers.
Like, you know, Slater ended up causing a red flag at one point.
So I'm not here to say that, you know, causing a red flag automatically means you're a sh** driver.
But again, Alex's lack of experience comes into play here.
I'm just glad he kept it out.
I'm just glad he kept it out of the wall, really.
Yeah, I'm more excited for Monza, though, because Monza is a track that Alex has a lot of experience on.
He did the Eurocup 3 weekend there earlier this year.
And even if qualifying doesn't go too well, because I know Prema, again, is not really great at the moment.
But even if he doesn't really qualify well, he's always been really good at overtaking at Monza.
I mean, we saw it in Eurocup 3 earlier this year where he, even though he started the race in P2, he stalled on the start, fell down to last, and overtook up to P10.
So we know he's good at overtaking, especially around Monza.
And yeah, as long as no one crashes into him, I think he should be fine.
I hope he can score some points at some point, either Monza or Madrid.
But like, I don't want to keep my expectations too high because I don't want to get disappointed.
But yeah, very exciting news.
I was very happy to hear this.
Because even though I am not really a big fan of Prema, any F3 experience is good.
And while Alex will be missing the Silverstone round of Euro Cup 3, I think a round of F3 experience is a lot more valuable to him.
Because, you know, if he's doing F3 next year, his championship position in Eurocup 3 right now is not great.
He's not in the title fight at all, but really, is anyone in the title fight?
I feel like Egozi’s just kind of going to run away with it.
But yeah, I think no matter where he finishes in the Eurocup 3 championship, it doesn't really matter.
So if he does miss a round for some F3 experience to prepare for next year, it's not that big of a deal.
Um, yeah, I am done.
Anyway, going to British F4, we had some pretty significant news before, well, midway through the official start of the race weekend.
And if you're a follower of British F4, you probably already know, but of course, it is that Dries- that Dries Van Langendock was going to be banned from the round after reaching 12 penalty points.
I mean, the whole handling of this was a mess.
Because he did practice on Thursday.
And then it was announced on Friday, oh yeah, he's banned by the way.
But the whole thing didn't make much sense to me at least.
Nobody seemed to really know this.
Rodin had no clue.
The thing is also that, if I remember correctly, and I have to check right now, he should have been banned before, like...
After the first round, 9 of the 12 penalty points came from last year.
Yeah, but like, from what I heard, he would have gotten enough, you know, penalty points already this season.
But they just decided to enforce the ban now, which again, it makes no sense.
Because he has raced multiple races with these apparently 12 penalty points on his license.
And usually, and it's a problem we see in feeder series, for most of them, it's said that you have to collect these 12 penalty points in the season you're currently driving in.
That is also what the British F4 regulations say.
If you're watching on YouTube, I hope Percy Wolff’s tweet about this will appear.
But look what he's found in the regulations and he said it should not apply.
I mean, it's probably what happened is, because we also have Joseph Smith banned, maybe they then realized, oh yeah, he's on 12 points technically, let's ban him as well.
Yeah, but I wonder if they like, decide to check and be like, hey, maybe we should look at other drivers too.
Or, and what I really hope did not happen, because that would be really whack, would be another driver being like, hey, but look at this or another team or just, you know, someone who's not from the people in charge of usually respecting these rules.
Because otherwise, I would expect them to keep track of these things and to be aware that he does have these 12 points.
I mean, he shouldn't even be, the fact that nine of them are from last year and the points should not carry forward should only be on three for this year.
And honestly, those three were undeserved, it is from round one in Donington from the incident with Palmer where he is not at fault for that.
It feels questionable anyways.
It feels like they're trying to bring the title fight closer.
And coincidentally, the driver who's in second, Lewis Wherrell, is British.
I'm really sorry for him because I said it online a handful of times already.
He has been driving a very, very solid season. He has been very good.
But no one will now talk about, oh, you know, he does good.
Everyone will just be like, because it feels like to a lot of people and I usually hate throwing out allegations,
but it feels like they're trying to, you know, not let either get the championship closer, get it more interesting or not let Dries win this,
which either ways, it's bullshit and it really is bad for the image of the championship.
Because if, you know, British, of course, one of the big ones, we have quite a few drivers who are not British.
If now non-British drivers have to fear that they'll be excluded or treated unfairly,
that would be massive and it could really damage the reputation of the championship.
Yeah, the whole thing is, on the commentary, Lewis, is just to, I mean, the commentary that he always talks about, how like in other series,
you don't get to see drivers getting banned as often as they do in British F4.
Unless it's someone, you know, like, like a Lacorte.
It's not common for drivers to get banned, but in British F4 it almost is, which is just insane.
It should even be normal because first you get three penalty points per incident.
It's almost as if they aren't actually being, they're being punished rather than having to learn from their mistakes,
because also, F4, it's your first step in single-seaters, like.
Obviously you have someone like Haarni Sadiq, who is on negative points and I haven't been keeping up.
I don't know if he has also been, you know, banned because I guess he should be at this point.
He's not, though.
Yeah, that's, it just does not make sense to me.
And we talked about this before in, I think it was, where was it?
We talked about this before in another championship where I heard someone say that maybe
stewards give, you know, stronger, you know, penalties to drivers that they see, you know, going further because it's more important.
Honestly, someone like Dries, you know, he will go far and you want to stop him from doing bad things early on.
So even if we don't agree with the penalties, maybe I could imagine penalty like Donington being,
even if in any other case he would not have gotten the penalty,
maybe, you know, being a bit stricter was a decision there to also hopefully help him
and make sure that he knows what's allowed and what's not allowed.
But in addition with the race ban, it just does not make sense to me.
It's just all a bit, it's just weird.
It's just, it's Motorsport UK who just basically mishandled all of this.
Or at least, as you said, as Alex said, hopefully nobody being like, have you looked at Dries?
I'm also really sad for Lewis Wherrell because from what I saw, he's closer in the championship now,
which, you know, I think he also had bad luck before.
So I'm not entirely, you know, it's difficult to say because I am a bit disappointed.
He's been unlucky being taken out anyway.
They've both been unlucky and ultimately whatever's happened here, it's not, it's not on him.
He's just been able to benefit, even though like it's not on him at all.
And he's still been able to drive, even if he's not first, he's still put himself in second.
Okay, but let's get to the races.
And just to mention also, we had with Kit Belofsky out, he’s still recovering from a concussion.
So hopefully he's able to recover.
Yes, so into the races and qualifying, we had Tommy Harfield with a double pole.
And of course, I think Alex O'Grady I want to talk a bit about because he was announced he was replacing DVL.
Unfortunately for him, because it was announced after Thursday practice, he missed both practice sessions.
So he's pretty much had to get straight into it.
But I believe he was doing quite, he just got a bit unlucky with the red flag.
So him starting down as low as he did, I don't believe it is fully representative,
but he did still out-qualify teammate Alfie Slater.
To be fair, to be fair, outperforming Alfie Slater is not, I don't think that's like a benchmark.
I think he'd be closer to Lennon without the red flag and more practice time.
That's the benchmark.
Did he even get any practice time at all?
I don't think he did.
I don't think he would have.
It is Donington rules, he can't really run on the Friday because then that would be all the practice on the Thursday.
And yeah, he had no practice.
So I'm just going to give a bit of a shout out to him because he took a difficult situation to be in,
to come in last minute.
Of course, you know, GB4 is still a different car, different team, a different set up to what he used to,
different drivers he wasn't against.
So into the first one.
I hope to see more from Tommy Harfield this weekend.
I was really hoping to get a win.
It just isn't meant to be, I guess.
He came in at race one, he loses the lead.
Race three, the crash with Jeff-Hall.
It's all a bit unfortunate.
I don't know, he does have the pace and I don't know, I quite like him as a driver as well.
I think his weekend was two parts unfortunate and two parts amazing.
It was great to see the poles.
It's just, it's not quite, I mean, race one, he still came second.
They're still solid enough and it's all about maintaining consistency.
But then race three, I think.
And it has been Harfield who's been penalised for the incident with Jeff-Hall.
I will be honest, I have not watched the race because it's been geoblocked here and my ITV will not work.
So I've not actually seen the incident myself.
I have and I feel, I don't feel like that was totally right to have happened.
It does just feel like Harfield was trying to make a move around the outside and got sort of caught up with Jeff-Hall.
Like, Jeff-Hall got air time is what I saw.
But I feel like Harfield was more just caught up in it.
It’s more of a racing incident it sounds like then.
Yeah, I feel like it was.
I feel like Harfield shouldn't have been, but as we've seen.
And then, I mean, it just ended up George Proudford-Nalder winning.
He's been quite, he's got quite a few wins this season.
He's also won at Silverstone as well.
He's kind of been flying under the radar almost, but he's been putting himself there.
And he is fifth in the standings, so that is quite a strong showing I feel like.
Yeah, he's been very consistent recently.
Yeah, I feel like, I want to give a shout out to Scott Kin Lindblom.
He won Race 2 reverse race grid.
And if you know me, I do quite like him as well.
I like him, but I feel like I was hopeful that he would do more this season.
I think he had some ups moments.
I think he did win Race 2, right?
Yeah, but reverse grid race.
Yeah, I think, I mean, that's good for him.
But like the middle of the pack around like Theo Palmer, Ethan Jeff-Hall, George Proudford-Nalder and Scott Kin Lindblom.
They're very close in the championship.
I think there's a good reason for that.
But also, I did expect him and I did hope him to be closer to the front, especially to Dries.
But, you know, I know he also had some problems.
I think he does not have as many, you know, I mean, he still probably has a lot of money, but he's not quite on the level of Dries.
I mean, Dries is insane, he's able to test with whatever FREC team he wants.
That is so funny, actually.
Every week he's testing with someone else.
He's now added Prema to that list.
I've said it, he's not testing with them, he's testing them.
He needs to figure out what's the best team.
I think, I'll call it now, it's almost certain that in 2028 he will be at either Trident or Campos.
And related to the teams themselves, it only matters who of them wins in 2027.
Yeah.
That will be the only choice.
It's going to be what should be the Prema FREC to Trident, F3 to Invicta, F2 pipeline, which is now starting.
Unless Campos keeps up being so dominant, because then he will do the Campos double in F3 and F2.
Especially if Tsolov should win this year, you know.
Yeah, definitely.
But we’re getting off track, I mean, DVL, yeah, Lindblom, I mean, I think also he gets involved in quite a few issues.
If he could tidy up his act, he can get involved in a few incidents sometimes.
And the Hitech has been outperformed by teammate Palmer.
But I think he does, I see him as someone with a bit of promise.
And I think he's just one of those drivers, he will just get better the more time they spend in single seaters.
We can't all be the new generational talent that can just out-drive everyone.
That cannot be everyone. It's fine.
He's still a great driver.
And I really enjoy his racecraft at times.
I think he can be really good at getting the overtakes done when he needs to.
And it was nice for him to finally get his first win.
I think this is his first win in quite a while.
He didn't get a win in Ginetta Juniors last year as well.
I think it's also a confidence boost as well for him to finally get a win.
And hopefully we can see some more positive results in the races from here on out.
I mean, looking at the standings overall, of course, DVL is still leading.
But as we kind of aforementioned, Wherrell is now only four points behind.
He basically had a weekend to gain points on him for free.
But I think as much as I talk positively about Wherrell, he could have maybe scored one or two points more this weekend.
And I think DVL was skilled, but it was also luck that he was so far ahead
because I was honestly almost expecting Lewis Wherrell to take the lead this weekend.
I have to say, the entire comedy was quite amusing this weekend with them.
They took by DVL's ban, and then they mixed up Lindblom and Van Langendonck.
I think both in Race 2 and Race 3, there were instances where the broadcast race died.
I mean, it's just standard at this point for feeder series.
We love those commentary breaks and just watching in silence.
I think the commentary break for Race 3 was especially funny because that was during the yellow flag
where three different people crashed in three different sectors.
And so it was just like a drone shot of everybody getting out of their cars and walking away in silence.
Cinematic.
Yeah, actually we did have a red flag in Race 3 as well.
Race 3, I don't know, it's F4. They're gonna crash into each other.
And it's not really anybody that's notable.
F4 moment.
In F1 Academy, the qualifying section was quite fun actually.
I don't know if you watched it.
But because we had like a drying track, that's always in the next track.
It's always interesting, like where they're going to go on the slicks.
And interestingly, despite two red flags, I don't know what was going on, but Ella Lloyd did not change on the slicks.
I'm honestly so sad about Ella Lloyd's horrible bad luck this season.
Because I was ready, and this is a really mean thing to say, but I was ready to be a bit more into that rivalry area.
Because I expected her to be right up in that title fight.
I expected it to be a close one between her and Alicia.
Because last year Ella Lloyd was the one who came out on top between the rookies.
And she is one of the drivers that I rate the highest here.
So to see this and to see, I don't know, if we can blame Rodin a bit for it.
But it's so incredibly sad actually.
It just makes me depressed.
For some reason, the second season, I don't know what it...
I think it's just been unlucky in this instance with the qualifying.
I feel like it's both on the driver and the team.
It's a mix of both.
The driver wants to go to slicks now, but the team can be like, oh, maybe we should go to slicks.
It's the decision both need to make.
And by that time, after the second red flag, pretty much everybody else was on slicks, apart from her.
And you can see in qualifying, they were having to overtake her. Of course on wets, you're not gonna have pace.
It was tough to watch.
I would judge her more if it was not for the fact that it feels like every single weekend she has a problem with the car.
There's some sort of mismanagement.
I'm just so disappointed. Majorly in Rodin.
I feel like her performance, even if she comes from back of the grid, is usually really, as I would expect Ella Lloyd to do it.
I really hope that next year we still see her in the racing.
And all she needs is things to go her way.
Because you can't look at results in terms of matter of driving.
You need to actually watch them.
Those who know Ella Lloyd know how good she can be.
I mean, as you said, last year, we were all going into the season expecting a Palmowski-Lloyd title fight.
Honestly, I went into the season and I was afraid that Campos could struggle because last year they were super fast with Chloe.
But bad things can happen sometimes and you never know.
But I can't believe that, you know, I'm so disappointed.
But I would also love to see a proper rivalry.
Either ways, for the qualifying, what I also wanted to add on, another team that I'm mad at is Hitech, who, as you should know, always runs the wild card car this weekend with Zoe Florescu.
And the thing is, from what I saw, or from what I remember, she qualified P7 originally.
She would have been P2 in the reverse grid race.
And I do believe that concerning her experience from Spanish F4, maybe she wouldn't have held on to that.
But I do believe that she could have definitely scored points.
Especially across both races with how Zandvoort exists as a track and for overtaking.
It's a shame that she ends up getting disqualified from qualifying.
I mean, it's kind of unfair because it's not the driver's fault that this happened.
The drivers themselves didn't do anything wrong.
It's just disappointing because this kind of performance, this kind of weekend is usually the one that could decide better if she gets the whole season's seat next year.
Because she didn't score any points now.
But we know qualifying P7, which I'm pretty sure she would have been above both full season Hitechs.
Who were the other two Hitechs?
Isn't it? I'm so stupid right now. I have nothing in mind.
I think it's Esmee Kosterman and Rachel Robertson, but I'm not sure about that.
Oh yeah, she was ahead of Robertson here because Robertson was meant to be in reverse grid pole and-
It's Dobson and Robertson.
Oh my god, it rhymes!
No, Kosterman is MP. Robertson is who? Dobson is-.
Dobson.
I mean, it's a great showing by her and it's becoming as minor as the engine lubricant did not meet the standards.
Like what?
It's also such an odd infringement that you don't hear about very often because you would generally not expect a team to have any other type of lubricant that isn't series approved.
Also, of course, it was Alicia on pole, but Alba Larsen had a really strong weekend, honestly.
I was impressed by her this weekend and I hope she can keep it up for her sake.
I mean, she did bring the experience from also racing here in British F4 pretty sure twice.
Yeah, yeah, she was also there last year and also F1 Academy last year here and I'm pretty sure they did midseason testing.
But also, I think Maya Weug, like, you know, supporting her.
She was with her in Zandvoort.
She was with her this weekend.
I think, and I said it before online, I think Maya has so much valuable experience and she knows what it's like to drive like Alba Larsen and she knows what it's like to deal with the pressure,
which she also knows what it's like to drive in, you know, these mixed weather conditions.
And I think I could imagine that's hope that really is valuable to Alba because apparently the second that things go her way and, you know,
she knows a bit of, she has a bit of experience and Maya is next to her, she gets podiums.
I think she always has the pleasure just about piecing everything together almost.
Like, I mean, race one was really good from her because she was starting seventh and she made her way up to second.
And race one was a really fun race.
Oh, yes.
We had Palmowski stall, which I think is the first mistake we've really seen from her this year.
But I'm unsure how much of it is a mistake because from what I read online afterwards, it was kind of maybe other people are just as biased as me because, you know, I like her.
I would not imagine that she would make a mistake like this.
But I saw some people point out that it just seemed like there was something wrong generally.
Oh, in the car.
Yeah, I'm not an expert.
I would not know.
I mean, even then, I mean, it's not like she's going to lose a ton of points from this, the big point here anyway.
On the main race on the Sunday.
Yeah, but lastly, she, you know, she made, let her overtake her way up to second.
Payton Westcott also had, you know, she won, but, you know, pole to win.
She was the biggest benefactor of the Florescu DSQ.
She was qualified ninth originally, but the Florescu DSQ, she made it to eighth in qualifying.
Otherwise, I don't think she would have been here.
And, you know, I wonder if instead of, you know, Westcott, who's, you know, she's in Prema, she's fast.
She has that Mercedes experience.
I wonder what would have happened if she was not in front of Larsen.
But Larsen would have had to overtake some like Florescu, who I do believe with her experience, especially around Zandvoort,
Larsen could have done easier if potentially we could have seen Larsen win this.
Yeah, I think she could have.
Because I think getting past Westcott is not something that's easily done,
especially not around Zandvoort when overtaking overall is a good thing that she managed to do that.
But overtaking wild card driver with less experience in Hitech after all,
I think it's a good thing that Alba seems to get onto that level of like Payton Westcott and those drivers who, you know,
they struggle and they have their bad days, but they also have their good days.
They have their, you know, good performances.
And that's important.
I think the second race’s podium is quite interesting because,
oh, it's not interesting because as expected feature race,
win once again goes to Alisha Palmowski, who has been absolutely dominant this season.
And besides the stall in the reverse grid race, I think she's been incredible.
I mean, race two is really strong from her.
And it showed, I think,her  better management skills compared to Larsen.
I mean, for like the first half, first half of the race, Larsen was right behind her.
But then Alisha managed to pull away about two seconds.
It is quite funny because Larsen's engineer was like, oh, she's starting the struggle, Alisha.
And Alisha just pulls away.
I think, you know, Alisha has shown she can do these 10 second advantage wins,
but especially around tracks like Zandvoort where we saw some drama and, you know, safety cars,
it's a good choice probably to not risk ruining your tires.
If you win by one second or 10 seconds, it's the same number of points.
Yeah, it would just be bad if there's a safety car and suddenly you're the one with f***ed tires,
while Alba behind you did not push as much and has an easier time than overtaking you.
But funny enough, Larsen in P2 and Gademan in P3 are the exact same as in the sprint race.
That's funny, I think.
Yeah, I mean, Gademan, she started fifth and she pretty much got up to third on the first lap.
Because other than that, we literally had no overtakes this race.
It was a... I don't even have much to say about the race, there's not much happened.
I mean, the main talking point, of course, is we talked about Alba and I hope she can take forward
the positive experience from this weekend.
I need to be mean to One Driver, which I'm very sorry about,
but I feel we saw weaker performance this weekend from Emma Felbermayr.
It was a messy weekend from her.
Yeah, like it was not bad per se, but with all the experience that she has,
and she did drive for British F4 already and she did the tests and she was here already last season,
I expected more from her and this is exactly the thing where, you know,
Alisha finishes as a winner once again and Emma finishes P5 and...
And in race one, she gets a penalty for the incident with Robertson.
Yeah, but the thing is, both her and Alisha didn't get points there,
so it's not as relevant to me in that point.
But the thing is, especially in the feature race where the big points are scored,
she needs to be up there with Alisha if she wants to keep up there,
because also she was, you know, outraced by Gademan, who's coming closer to her in the championship.
And I feel like I saw someone post that Alisha could pretty, well not easily,
but she has a good shot at winning the championship in somewhere in America.
Oh yeah, and yeah, she basically, yeah, I'll have a post up here.
She needs to outscore, so Felbermayr would need to outscore her by nine points
and Gademan needs to outscore her by 28.
So, I mean, as long as she just continues what she's doing, she'll be fine.
Like, Gademan needs to be quite lucky to get up there, and Felbermayr,
I mean, nine points does not sound like a lot, but look at this, like...
Like, as long as Alisha wins, like, of course COTA will have three races.
But that means Alisha also has three races, and Camps seems really strong.
She's clearly, you know, the main focus of the team,
which is also a bit of luck on her, because Rafael Ferreira just has not been where,
you know, anyone would have hoped her to be.
Megan Bruce has been strong, but it has been pretty obvious
that the team has been focusing majorly on Alisha
and as a rookie, I think that's also more fine for Megan,
who probably can learn something from Alisha's great performances.
Yeah, so I think, I mean, if you look at the standings, Alisha's first with 136,
Emma's second with 88 points.
If you even look at the teams, Rodin as a team have 139 points,
Alisha has 136, one person versus three.
Yeah, and I mean, it's so sad.
Like, I'm stuck on the point with Ella Lloyd,
and Megan Bruce is like currently P6 in the championship,
matched on 49 points with Westcott in P5, but, like, she has more wins.
And she's pretty close there.
I think she could still end up at least in the top four,
because Larsen also only has 50 points.
Which, I mean, think about how much she gained this.
She gained 25 points this weekend.
She's pretty much doubled her points tally.
Yeah, but I think Bruce is one of the drives
that I think hasn't been really surprising positively,
but also car’s good, you know, all the stuff.
But if we are already talking about F1 Academy,
and, you know, we're talking a lot about things that have happened around this year.
We've had my favourite, my favourite things happen once again,
which is the now annual F1 Academy rookie test,
which is additionally this year, not just, you know,
one day of driving in two sessions,
but it also adds, like, a little training camp at a university
somewhere in Britain where they do media stuff,
they do physical training, they do all that stuff.
I don't go to a British university.
I don't know how these work.
Loughborough is like a sport uni.
Can you give us input on what you think of the university?
It's great for sports.
It's literally like, if you think about, like, Olympians and stuff,
they go to this university, it's really good for sports.
They have amazing sports facilities.
You know, it makes sense to host and get there,
just because they have the facilities for all the training, the gym.
So they're, like, probably also already experienced
with, you know, connecting athletes on one hand side to,
you know, probably also, like, sports management majors
and, like, doctor stuff, people and physicians and all of that.
So I think it's a good thing.
Do we want to look at some...
I don't want to go through every single one,
but if someone listening to this wants to hear direct opinions,
they're always on my Twitter account.
A slight plug over there.
I mean, I could read down everything I've written,
but I don't think that's something that interests everyone.
So I'll just point out my most important notes,
which, first of all, and it's something that I'm very, very happy about,
the choice for drivers this year is super diverse.
Last year, we had majorly...
We only had, like, European drivers,
three North American drivers and one driver from Australia,
the rest European,
three of those from the United Kingdom,
four of those from France.
The thing is, I get it.
In Europe, we have the biggest car culture.
We have most of the sponsors, most of the big karting facilities.
Internationally, it's a difficult thing to step up from, you know,
karting to Formula Series,
because you also know Formula Four, all the big ones, are based in Europe.
The big teams are based in Europe, and it goes like that.
Formula Regional Europe is the most respected one.
Formula Three, Formula Two mainly drive in Europe.
I think, I mean, Japan has Super Formula Lights,
and the Super Formula Universe,
but generally, and the same way that America has in the next,
and like, I always forgot, it's a three letter, it's like...
USF Pro, USF Pro 2000, USF Junior.
Yeah, these things, they exist, and sometimes they have really good grids,
but it's generally regarded as, in Europe, you have stronger grids,
and we also see drivers who want to go to IndyCar come to Europe,
like Sebastian Wheldon,
because, I'm sorry, but Italian F4 is internationally just the biggest and the best,
even if sometimes an F4 Series in America has also great drivers,
you will never have a grid featuring 50 drivers on, you know,
these huge, super important circuits that just happens not as often,
which makes it really hard for international drivers.
And anyways, in 2026, we cover five continents,
we have three Asian drivers, which is great,
considering that so far in the whole history of F1 Academy,
and full season drivers, I have not counted Wildcard drivers,
but we also only had three Asian drivers.
We have a handful of European drivers, notably none from the UK,
which I find fascinating,
but also we have enough of those.
We have three North American drivers,
and we have one driver from Africa, to be precise, from Morocco,
and one driver from South America.
So it's a very diverse grid,
and what I find super important is that most of the drivers already have experience in F4,
but they're not all from, you know, only French F4, British F4,
but we also have drivers coming from Kyojo Cup, coming from GB4,
coming from...
There's a championship in America,
and I'm trying to say the title because it's really long.
It's like Formula Pro United States of America,
something like that.
It's insane, but, you know,
I think it's good that we have such a diversity
because it also makes it more accessible to talk about these drivers,
how do they drive against each other,
which championships are maybe better than we give them credit for,
or which drivers are better than we give them credit for,
but have not had the chance to prove themselves yet.
Notably, Alexia Danielsen, Autumn Fischer, and Eva Dorrestijin
are returning after already competing in the Rookie Test last year.
Alexi Danielsen was the fastest driver who would not go on to score a seat in F1 Academy,
while one or two drivers slower than her did.
I was kind of confused by that,
but, you know, we'll see what she does this year.
We have the Wild Cards...
Who was it?
Autumn Fischer and Zoe Florescu also returning,
and what's heavily rumored,
Luna Fluxa Cross to be a Wild Card in America,
and Jordan Deva-Martin, who...
Jordan comes from GB4,
where the highest-placed female driver
gains a championship prize of, like, 50,000 pounds,
which covers... I think an F1 Academy season at most is limited at 100,000,
so it's, like, half the season covered.
She's one of the ones we expect to see next year.
We see a few drivers coming over from French F4,
like Clara Stiebleichinger,
which is a horrible name, by the way,
and also... Who was it?
I have the list open, but I have to think about it.
Sofia Zanfari, definitely,
and kind of Ginevra Panzeri,
but Ginevra Panzeri, we talked about it,
she's pretty much already announced to be racing with
Visa Cash App Racing Bulls
in F1 Academy next year,
and other than that, we have quite a few drivers
just with one or two seasons of F4 already,
one or two drivers who come from karting,
and one area that I find fascinating is Carmen Kraav,
who actually comes more from sports cars, to be precise,
the NLS, the Nürburgring Langstrecken Serie,
which could be named to some for Max Verstappen's
driving there.
I wonder how she can compare to other drivers
with more experience, but more notably,
she is in the NLS racing with
WS girls only,
no, Girls Only by WS racing, that way around,
and that's the team where also Carrie Schreiner
and Chloe Chong drive, so I wonder how much more
we could see F1 Academy interact with that team,
and put female drivers further into sports cars.
Interestingly, there's no Ella Hakkinen
on the Rookie Test list.
I have to say something about Ella Hakkinen,
which is that she is part of More Than Equal,
as far as I remember, is she actually,
maybe she's not, please cut that, I don't think she is,
I think I'm making s*** up. No, she's part of the McLaren
Junior Academy, but both McLaren cars will be driven
by More Than Equal drivers, which are
Alexia Danielson and Zoe Florescu,
because McLaren is really heavy
on their support with female drivers. They have
three female drivers in their driver academy,
Ella Lloyd, Ella Stevens, and Ella Hakkinen,
and they also had invited
the More Than Equal girls, including Alexia Danielson.
I don't know if they were invited,
but they were in the McLaren garage
in Zandvoort this weekend,
and it was officially announced, which is interesting
because we did not see it last year,
it was officially announced that they will be
doing the rookie test with
the McLaren cars, and I wonder
if we could potentially see
even more inclusion
of women in McLaren,
because also, as we know, McLaren
is not just racing in F1,
but they also have their team in IndyCar,
their team in World Endurance Championship,
I have to think for a second if I say WEC or W E C,
I could imagine
them taking over
more women, because also
Mika Hakkinen has been very
involved in female racing drivers
and working with McLaren, which I really love.
It will be interesting to see where all these drivers
end up next year, of course.
I think it's important to remind
for last year,
the top six drivers all got a seat
in F1 Academy, and most notably
Ella Stevens, who came
right from karting, got her seat
that way, because
she was really surprising to be faster
than I think last year was Lisa
Billard and Payton Westcott,
and she was really, really
quick last year, which I think is part of
what gave her that seat, and would also help
others prove that they have
the needed speed, and I could
definitely see if a driver
we don't quite expect to see in the grid yet,
like, you know, we have a handful of drivers
that we do expect to see, but if someone like
Clara Stiebleichinger drops
the fastest time, I think that would
heavily improve the way
teams and sponsors look at her
and give her a better chance.
But I think it's really nice that there are so many
women where we say, oh, I would have thought
she would be here, oh, I would have expected her
to do this. It's a great thing, because
it just shows that we have so many new young
female racing drivers that we did not
have before, not in these masses,
that having one rookie test with 18
drivers, we could fill that like three or four
times now. We couldn't have done that
three or four years ago. Is there anything
left to say? Uh, no, I don't think so,
so we can just outro now.
Uh, thanks to everyone for listening to this
week's episode of the Grand Prixquel podcast. We hope
you enjoyed it. And yeah, and enjoy
Robin's rant about Alex Powell. Well, more like a
happiness rant this time. Uh, next week
or next episode we'll be covering the
I believe will be the F2 and F3
rounds at Monza. I love Monza.
Yeah, Mr. Monza Banking.
That's really a surprise.
Alex monzabanking loves Monza.
Anyways, until next time, everyone.